papon en fuite l'ancien haut
fonctionnaire de vichy invoque la
république et les droits de l'homme pour
justifier son geste
dès demain matin la cour de cassation
devrait constater son absence sa
condamnation à dix ans de prison
deviendra définitive et c'est ensuite
qu'un mandat d'arrêt pourra être lancée
récit et réactions avec roselyne febvre
dans le journal sud-ouest maurice papon
justifie sa décision de ne pas se
constituer prisonnier je ne veux pas
mendier ma liberté dit-il
alors il se l'octroi et choisit l'exil
dans le journal ils posent au soleil
l'air décontracté à droite un journal
posé sur la table
après vérification il s'agirait d'un
magazine espagnol alors l'ancien
fonctionnaire de vichy et il est en exil
là bas ou s'agit-il d'une manipulation
personne ne peut y répondre ou ne veut
tirer pondre au moment où nous envoyons
le communiqué de maurice papon indiquant
qu'il a choisi des villes on peut
imaginer que effectivement il avait déjà
quitté sa patrie comme il dit et vous
savez où il est parti oui mais je ne
vous le dirais pas d'ailleurs cette
information n'a pas d'intérêt pour les
avocats des parties civiles
rien d'étonnant à ce départ arno
klarsfeld avait alerté à plusieurs
reprises la chancellerie il avait même
par deux fois demandé un contrôle
judiciaire et a n'a été fait ce qui est
quand même exceptionnel pour quelqu'un
qui a été condamné à 10 ans de réclusion
pour complicité de crime contre
l'humanité
et bien pour qu'il puisse avoir son
passeport il puisse narguer la justice
qui puisse poser ses conditions et
qu'ils puissent s'en aller sans que le
lait le gouvernement sans que la justice
cherche à le retenir donc il y a quand
même des responsabilités et maurice
papon a été protégée pour s'en aller
michel slitinsky est l'homme qui a
révélé le passé de maurice papon 15 ans
de recherches et de bataille judiciaire
aujourd'hui l'attitude de papon ne l'a
pas surpris je vois que papon a été un
serviteur zélé de vichy et qu'il
aujourd'hui et il se trouve être un
profanateurs de des idées de la
république et de sa justice
à mon avis je crois que papon est un
homme
un cas particulier un phénomène qui
manquent pour la perversité des gens de
vichy pour les avocats des parties
civiles ce n'est pas un coup de théâtre
il s'y attendait mais la fuite de
l'homme qu'ils ont réussi à faire
condamner et pour eux difficile à
accepter